OK. Greetings. A couple of things to cover.
Just at the big hi. I hope you're all talking about tech.
A couple of things to cover at the beginning. I mean, some people have said, what about the guest accounts that there that they have for this week?
When are they going to disappear? And and, well, you know, I guess we think they won't stay open forever.
But I would appreciate if you'd just write me a note saying how long you would like them to.
If you want it after Friday, say about how many days and why you'd like to have it after.
Because so far we we are in over our allocation, but the disk at this space is tight.
This morning when I logged in, it was there was only one hundred and two blocks left.
And so that's I mean, people this goes up and down all the time.
But we can't provide free access to to anyone who wants it just because they sat in on this class, I guess.
But, you know, the purpose of the class was to get you started on it, after which if you like it, then then you have to either pay or.
Ah ah ah ah ah. Well, wait for the for the cannon machines to come to you to the other parts of the campus, I'm afraid.
Now let's see. Another thing is that when I log in the computer this morning,
it said that it was scheduled to go down tonight at five o'clock for us for some software development.
So now that sometimes they sometimes they they forget about and don't come in.
But. But this since I had asked them to try to avoid all downtime this week, but maybe they had to at least do one one.
So 5:00 is usually the time that's down. So maybe one out of five days they had to do it.
So. So I'm afraid that tonight, from five to eight o'clock, the machine is scheduled not to be running.
So let me see if I have any good news.
OK, now the for tomorrow, I would like any I would like to respond to the stumbling blocks that that you people are having personally.
And so I would appreciate it very much if you if you would talk to me after class today or or or or send a note of some kind to my secretary
or not to me to be at least an hour before tomorrow's class so that I have time to look at the problems that people are actually having.
I want to plan all tomorrow's class based on the problems, starting with the most easily answered problems and the most elementary ones,
and then going on to the if if if nobody is really stuck on on very easy things and everyone wants to hear about how do you write output routines?
Well, we're talking about how to write auto routines but or alignments or something.
But but what if there's something? Don't be embarrassed to say that.
That you're having trouble with something.
That's the purpose of discourse is to his thing is to have you surround any hurdle that that appears to be there.
So let me know either right after class today or sometime anyway before tomorrow.
So that I can plan tomorrow's lecture to to get everybody over the hump.
Let's hope today. I wanted to talk about what was a little bit of continuation over what we said yesterday,
what it means when when Texas says nasty things to you and why and why these things seem reasonable to the computer to two responses.
And also, I wanted to talk a little bit about how you can get techs to do slightly different things that you might that you might be interested in.
OK, Nancy. So where was I yesterday?
I was beginning to show a I was beginning to show something about overflow boxes.
And that's one of the main things I want to talk about. How many of you have gotten message saying some boxes over for?
Oh, how many of you have not? OK.
So only a few people raise hands and the overflow boxes is a strange thing that tech does that no other system does.
And I'm going to try to defend it if I can today.
Now me see what else can I say. It is a brief review of what we did yesterday.
Oh I see. I think this was your.
Notice, here is a case I was looking ahead in someone's in someone's file.
And there was a different kind of error in that one than we saw yesterday.
The first one here. You can't do that in math mode.
And the thing that you couldn't do was equation No.
Now, now that I think you noticed that I did use equation number, but that was display math.
So. So you can't do an equation number in math mode.
So it's only for display math. No. Well, now, if you get to look at this error message is this.
This is one of these six line ones. This is an argument to something.
And this is and you don't even know what the thing is.
But here we see what we're actually tech has read has read up to page two, line nineteen, and it's read up until the double dollar sign.
So it should be. It looks like it's in display math mode in a way, doesn't it?
But actually, now looking at this, I see. Oh, there's a carriage return here.
So what this is probably is is an example of a queue, a line,
which is the which is the subroutine in the control sequence in basic that's used to line up things.
So I'll make a quick review of EQR line here. Queue a line is what you type.
If you want to get like equate equal signs.
A line like you can say a. And then you, you type a tab mark which is this on the keyboard.
It's the same key as the asterisk. But top asterisk and then you type equals some, some messy formula like square root of, of whatever.
OK. And then you say backslash C are at the end of the first equation.
And then to line up the second one you might like this equation might even end with a comma.
And then the second one you could say B some I.
And then you give your tab Mark and then you would say equals.
And then you have some other formula slash S.R. and then maybe there will be a third line which has nothing to the left of the equal sign.
And this you might say, less than or equal to one over and or something.
Whatever you've got here, period.
And then another slash C, R and A right. Brace.
Now this would come out looking like this A equals square root of something of whatever.
On the first line then B Sabai equals.
And then you see your next line here. Less than are equal on over N.
Period. And this would all be centered finally.
So. So so the text would know this isn't the real example.
I'm just making it up now. But you've seen this a lot of times where you have a series of equations and you want to have all the things aligned.
And these two have marks. Here are the things that that they tell take where to what's what what position to to line up is comes before the relation.
So that's fine, except that this person. Now this is all explained in the manual.
Well, let me see. You have. Can I borrow the manual for a second.
OK. Q A line of find that the index and it's on page ninety two to ninety six is all about that.
OK. So, so it appears in the manual and and gives you some examples of EQR line.
And here was one of the examples in the book that worked out the first one.
It did. So there was several things on the left of the equal sign here and on the right.
OK. So this so it lines everything up and pushes pushes everything to the right on the left part size and the right and sides move to the left.
And then here is an example with an equation number, in fact. But after the EQR line, then I have an equation number in that equation.
No gets gets centered. With respect to the two line equations, it's not on the bottom line of the two there.
Now, sometimes all you've got have alignment. And also maybe the first line is number two.
The second line is number two or both lines are numbered.
OK, well, then there's this other there's this other thing, which is explain at the bottom of the page, EQR line with optional numbers.
And this one is the the thing to use.
And in that case and in there you put another tab, Mark. If there's a number on that line instead of.
Things like the you put another one of these funny looking tab marks.
So here is a tab before the equals and here the tab before the equation number twenty nine.
Or if I had done it for the above, for the for the earlier equation and I wanted to just number the second equation,
then I would give no number for the first line. I give a number for the second line.
This EQR line number always puts the equation number at the right.
Those people who like a style that does it at the left, there's help coming in other macro packages, but not in basic.
Basic does not have that basic. It's very basic.
It doesn't have all the bells and whistles that people can think. All right.
So now that the cure then for the person who had this problem of equal number
in trying to put it in the middle of the EQR line before a carriage return,
it doesn't go. It can't do that in math. No, it would have to go after it here.
In fact, it looks like there's in here it's complaining about equation number one. And I can see equation number two is in there.
Now, tech has has actually not seen the error until it got to the end of the holy EQR line,
because it it it first it first chews up the entire argument to secure line the entire thing in brackets,
in braces after a cue line and feeds that to the EU line control sequence.
So it won't catch the error immediately because the two line crossing and then
the start to work on it until after it's after the whole thing has been done.
So now the next one, equation number two, also then was considered to be an error on the same page two.
Line nineteen is the source then. Then the problem came, of course, also on line 26 when with the equations four and five.
Okay, so that's something to keep in mind.
The difference between aligning equations with and without numbers and the the the other other macro packages that go beyond basic will give you more,
more options like this for it's more, more kinds of things that can happen.
Now, the difference you might say, well, why not just have EQR line number and not EQR line at all?
Because you could always you know, you could always just use EQR line number without putting a number in there.
Now it's your third parameter. Well, then you wouldn't have the then you wouldn't have the chance to get this.
This this number here is centered the way it was.
Because so EQR align without the number makes a box that can be used in a formula just like anything else.
So if you so you can have an equal line of something and then you can continue a formula
and say quod another EQR line and get to two sets of a equations in the same formula.
So you could have you could you could say E Carolina something and you could get A equals something and B equal something.
And then you give another EQR line that would give you a C equals and vehicles to the right of that.
If you'd send equal line, finished that one and then. And then another equal in the same form.
Equal line number. You can't do that. Equal line numbers make something other.
That's all that's prepackage. So that. So that's the result of it.
Is this the width of an entire of an entire line.
Because it's got to get. Got to be ready to put that equation a number. You q align itself without the number.
Just makes the box as big as it's necessary. So this was the result of the first secure line.
This would be the result of a second secure line. Now this isn't going to go both of these are centered with respect to each other.
So if they aren't exactly the same size, it might look a little funny.
Like if suppose C starts out with a big integral sign and all these other formulas are very are very small,
like a equals zero equals one sees, does it begin to go saying, well then this box is gonna look bigger in order to center it?
It's going to it's gonna move this box up a little bit.
And so that wouldn't that wouldn't work very well. So I'm sorry,
but equal line doesn't do everything and not nor will any one control sequence do everything that you could ever possibly expect it to do.
So EQR line will build a box for the size of these things.
But but if one is larger than the other, that they'll be center with respect to each other.
And general alignments we could talk about tomorrow.
If there's if there's enough interest. But EKU align itself is just a abbreviation for something that you could type a bunch of.
You would say V box of H align o something or other and and you end.
You could learn how to type those those lower level things v box of H line yourself and and make those alignments.
If you want some, some really special effect. What if what, what I found was though how that EQR line and equal line number.
We're able to handle, you know, the first of the first two hundred pages of mathematics that I that I have personally had to typeset.
And that was that sample that I. That I chose influenced the way I define basic.
I just took everything and I made basic to everything that I was a. I thought I needed to do in a into underpays is pretty, pretty varied stuff.
But still, it wasn't it didn't it didn't vary as much as as the diversity in applied physics and and statistics or something like that,
the way people would want to use that. So other other sets of formats besides basic will certainly be certain to be made up.
OK. Now any questions on that? The next thing I don't I don't know why this happened.
Undefined control sequence, backslash three. It might have been meaning to say two thirds and type.
This was just a very used to hitting the backslash key instead of the slash key by now, because here is this quired right in front of it.
So maybe it just meant two thirds but unconfined.
So backslash three undefined control sequence is certainly not defined.
That hasn't been defined yet. On the other hand, these control sequences backslash zero, backslash one and so off the backslash nine.
Well, it's the I, I, I have defined backslash nine, I guess in appendix E, but not in basic.
And an intent is in most macro packages to leave those,
to leave those control sequences undefined so that no matter what macro package you have then then this,
these are going to be handy ones for you to make up for an abbreviation for something like that.
You can see that you're gonna be typing ten times so you could define backslash three to be a C,
a set of twenty characters that you don't want to have to type. Over and over again and just say backslash three and each time instead.
So. So these would be convenient to remember that all of those control sequences are reusable for,
for you and, and don't have a special meaning in a in a macro package.
Now here's an undefined control sequence. No, you can see what the intent of that one was.
Right. I'm sorry that control sequences don't jump.
Well, no, I'm not sorry because otherwise you couldn't do very much with them with control sequences if we if they were all to jump spaces.
But that's why we have these funny line control sequences with all words mixing together noin dent, you know, eqr line.
That's not always pronounceable, but you'd need to get it as a control sequence.
You tend to run run into long words.
Now you know what's gonna happen if you, if you just, if you just press carriage return on after this error, what's gonna happen.
These please use the microphone or be included in the text as it turns out, and we'll be included in the text as a word.
Not only that, it'll be indented. All right. Okay.
So it'll say in you know, there'll be a blank space and then it'll say.
And then. OK. Right. OK. Now what if this.
What if you wanted to correct that as you were going as you were going through just so that it wouldn't appear in your eyes.
But maybe you'd like to see it all, because that'll be a good reminder that you've got to correct this afterwards.
But suppose you you wanted to know this was the only mistake in your own.
In your file. And you wanted to get the output right away. And get over with.
How could you correct this without restarting Tak. Susan.
I can't remember how to delete. But I would delete six characters. OK.
Yeah. You delete six by typing a six. You type A six to get rid of the and D.N.A.
And then it would stop again, give you another chance. And then I insert the slash.
No. Yeah. And you type an iron. And then slash no.
And then with no space. And then you, you are on your merry way.
OK. That's that's the review of yesterday and certain delete.
OK. Now I wanted to talk about overfill boxes.
Question. I can't see how dark. How do I get equal lying.
And assemble before the equation. Explain.
Explain to me how you get this symbol.
Tamar. Oh OK.
Well, this is on on the. It's it's possible that anscar they have defined this to be some other symbol at scale.
It's defined to be a character that's on the same key as the asterisk, which is Nuk which is right up an upper right hand corner of the screen.
Jake. Yes. It's control.
E control. V. OK. Control V on score for that.
For that. Oh yeah. I remember now. Question. Question.
Yes. With respect to that last example with the No. One. Yes.
Is the space considered a character that hasn't been read or has been read.
This face following a control sequence is always ignored.
So you put inserted just slash. Now then what?
Then they get the desired effect. The space, the space after T after the T of no indent has not been read.
Because you only deleted six characters.
But then when you were in sort of control sequence, that space will be ignored because it follows the control sequence,
the spaces between the know the space between the no and the indent.
Right. Would be ignored in any event because after a control sequence spaces ah ah ah ah.
Neglected. So even if it were so it must have been, it must have been read in order to have been, in order to break it.
But you could it's right when it's hard to tell whether it was on the first line of the second line of when it's a space.
Yeah that's right. You can't see the spaces there. It's perhaps perhaps an hour later implementation of tech will have some way to display
of a visible symbol that supposed to mean a space just so you could you could tell.
Sometimes sometimes your file contains not a space,
but it's have Mark and then that it just shows us several spaces on the screen to those as if they were as if as if there were spaces.
Similarly, if you have a if you give. Force bases in a carriage return, it's very hard to see those four spaces are in the line.
So that's why the rules of tech have been dry, have been set up, so that unless you do something strange that we can talk about next week,
that where you want this feature usually spaces at the end of a line before a carriage
return space at the beginning of a line or tag marks the beginning of the next line.
All have exactly the same effect to take, which is as if there was only one space.
This is so that so that these visual puns don't don't interfere with what the actual behavior tech is.
Because otherwise you'd look you stare at the phone,
you'd never see that it was doing something strange only because there was a space before the carriage return.
So the rules have been intentionally made so that this is so that this wouldn't be a kind of problem which would be minimized.
You know, I want to talk about overfill boxes. And here's a little episode.
This is one of the students of the class who was most most ambitious, perhaps.
I think she went to my secretary and said what? What was the most complicated paper Knuth ever wrote?
And Phyllis gave her a reprint of this particular one.
And she said, OK, that will be her project for. And.
And she started out and it's a paper called Notes. And generally it can sums and she started to type it end.
And, well, we had some we use this as one of the examples yesterday.
But then we didn't talk about the next thing where it started, say, overfull box point five nine four four two,
why and and what it meant or what this overfill box usually means is that Tech was
trying to typeset a paragraph and it didn't find a good way to break the lines.
And so as a result. And I'll tell you why in a minute.
It has set one line too long.
Instead of making you had a choice, it could either set one line to spacy or it could it or it, you know, or or it could set one line too long.
And in both cases, you'd like to know about it.
You'd like to have some kind of a message saying that that that there's something unusual about this paragraph.
Unless you don't care about a line as too spacey, in which case you would like you would prefer to have it on line.
It's too spacey and not even be told. OK. Now you can get all those effects from tech.
But if you if you don't want very spacey lines, then it then it'll give you an error message of one sort or another.
It would either have to set a line to space and say, watch out.
There is a line over there that's that's that that that really violates here.
You're constrained on spaces, but otherwise the paragraph at least doesn't have anything sticking out.
The alternative would be to also have the bad lines sticking up and give an error message.
Now, the philosophy the tech has is since it is an error, there was a non error message, a warning message.
This is not an error. You don't have it just goes on your terminal. But it doesn't.
It's not really like an error. It doesn't stop you and ask you to do anything. It just tells you that's happened.
Now, the tech thinks the philosophy that you're going to want to correct it anyway,
since since your your tolerance, unwise basis said that this that this was it wasn't any good.
And so by putting the overfill line, you'll be able to look at the line and see how much is going to fit on that line.
So what it does is it squeezes that line together as much as it can and you'll see if it sticks out.
No actual output is here. The first line was sticking out a little bit.
That first remands, it didn't fit. And now how did I know that it was that line?
It doesn't show too well here, you know. And they said here it was just, well, less than a point over and a point is 30.
Seventy second of an inch, literally a little less even. So, you know, this is rather small potatoes here, but it's it's over for, in fact,
that you don't even get this message if it's less than a tenth of a point.
But but I didn't know it was that line because because I could look at this at
this strange this strange stuff afterwards here with these dots in front of it.
And that was telling me what the box was they've got to right now.
Maybe somebody will implement tech a different way sometimes so that these these overfill box messages are a little easier to read.
But what this is, is really a printout of the of what the back of the awful box looks like to tech at its funny machine oriented level.
And it's a little bit interesting anyway, if you wonder what's going on inside of this strange, strange program.
As I said yesterday, it's the book. The goals of of tech are to build boxes and they make them either horizontally or vertically.
And this is a box that was overfull, but it was H in each box.
Now the contents of the box are listed down below with with dots in front of it.
And the first thing that each box was another each box. And then came a character from Fonte a W capital W and then came an H.
And Ian and N. So if you learn how to read this way, that's when.
OK. Not only that, but this, this H box here is in front of the way.
Now let me explain to you, because it because actually if you start to understand the lowest level effect, guys,
some of the other things all of a sudden come in clearer, even though you don't have to think about the low level all the time is something.
Now, what does these other strange things? Well, the first it gives the height of the box, the depth of the box and the width of the box.
So here's a box. This all in point. So this is a box that's six point nine points high and that's above the baseline.
And this is about two points below the baseline. And then it's about three and sixty one points wide.
And that's much wider than it should be. Actually, it should have been smaller.
And then the glue set minus one means that everything has been shrunk as much as possible.
Glue said, is zero means everything is its normal with glue.
Said his positive means everything is stretched a little bit according to
proportional to the amount of glue set and glue said minus one means that this is.
They all look all these faces in the line. The glue has been compressed as much as possible.
The next H box is. Is doesn't have anything in it, but it's.
And it doesn't have any height. It doesn't have any depth. It's just 20 inches wide.
This is the indent at the beginning of paragraph.
Here's a 20 point indented beat that that you get at the beginning of the paragraph was it was a box that was just invisible,
doesn't have anything in it, but it was 20 points wide. So that was two ends of indent at the beginning of the paragraph, followed by the word win.
So when you get an awful ballpark's message, you scan down in and you see what's in the box.
And you can usually use that to figure out the beginning of the line in case you can't see the line sticking out.
At least I would know that it started out with an indentation and a word win.
And so then I could I could find it. OK. But there is nothing printed on the page saying where the awful box was.
The reason is that tech is pretty much at this point.
It doesn't even know where it's gonna go on a page yet because it's got boxes gonna be passed to other people,
other other parts of tech before it gets done and all. It doesn't know which where it came from in the source anymore.
That's all been you're at your original input has all been massaged into some horizontal list and then broken into Pyhrric pages and so on.
So all tech can really do is say that it's had to make an overflow box somewhere
and can't really very easily remember where it came from in the source file.
I could have built in extra things in tech that would remember this, but it hasn't turned out to be necessary now.
So going back here then, that was how I found it. I guess I could see an indentation of 20 points and then the word win.
And that must be the line that there weren't any others on.
OK, now we go through this little example a little bit further. And and here the strategy in this case was two was after the first error message.
The strategy here was to to hit line feed instead of carriage return.
A line feed, says Flash. All the other elements don't even stop for anything because you sort of say
there's going to be lots of areas if let me see them all and dump them off at me.
And so on. These next error messages that come from the there, there isn't even a place for for a response.
And there's no up arrow here saying do something to it because the Langfield had been hidden.
And we're just going right through the very beginning. Here is a missing left.
Brace was inserted. See it? Read each box one and this backslash, each box, it turns out, has to always be followed by a left brace.
And this is a rather complicated thing for a first exercise. But here it was,
the H box type with the left base after so tech inserted a left brace there and said that it's going
to read this one one over again and then manual read the other things and it's done all these things.
But now it turns out that that this one error has caused everything to get mixed up.
And this is typical. You you start working computer programs that process the files and very often your first error message is close to the truth.
After that, if you get ten more error messages, they might have nothing at all to do with any real errors because the first
error has screwed things up so royally that there's no way to get back in sync.
In this particular case,
the fact that the left brace was missing meant that the that the the the arguments to certain control sequences were completely or completely wrong,
because the the the way that left and right braces match up with each other is the whole
clue to what gets passed to two to a control sequence with what belongs to center.
If you said center line and you forgot the left brace, but then but it would you would you might bring in all kinds of weird parts of your text.
So now after this, just about everything is meaningless after this point.
And so you get lots and lots of things. In fact, not only was there a missing one, then it turns out there's an extra right missing left one.
There was an extra right one. And pretty soon there was some extra right ones.
And then they probably find some missing right ones also. Everything will get screwed up pretty soon.
And so this is an illustration then not. Don't be alarmed if you get a 100 error message is only the first one might be a real error.
The rest of them might just be because there was there was no obvious way to recover from the first.
From the first day we tried to best to recover. But sometimes when when it's a case of Brace's being mismatched or or something.
So if you have to go awhile before you get back in sync now.
So this particular thing came to came came through a lot of text going going through
the whole text in a completely crazy ways until finally it generate an overflow box,
seven thousand two hundred ninety seven points to my right.
So this is very glorious. So what it did was it made the rest of the rest of the paper into a mathematical formula.
With all kinds of beautiful alignments and everything, and and so we did get that box out there.
And finally we were able to get the program to end. And what happened?
Well, we sent it to the printer. This was to the GOP.
And at the time, this was the first day the daughter wasn't working and the printer got to got to that long formula and cut the page right there.
You see the pages very short. Can you see this? It just gave up right there.
And then. And it's and there's a little, you know, wild things are here and there.
You can probably find, you know. So we didn't get to see all this yards and yards of formula that are sticking out over for OK now.
So that's that's also what might happen.
You might get over four boxes because you you have a very large formula or something that got put into a guy's got put into a box.
For now, the story has a happy ending. That namely after fixing after putting in that left, that left, right brace and one or two other things.
Then the next time a whole page about output came through and it was still a little bit.
There was a problem with over here not being now with a left brace in front of the over so that that the farmers work.
So this there should have been a left brace to see what goes over what.
But you see, at least we're getting something that that you can read and you can look at.
And that's a lot more encouraging than overfull box of a thousand points.
You know, a point is small. Eight thousand points is large. OK.
And then. Then the next.
And then after, you know, now it was easy to look at this and see and just patch a couple more things and then came out something in and over,
started working also that afternoon. So everything was very, very lovely. And.
And the output started coming out. Right. We got the J overkeen everything.
All these formulas are coming, coming out nicely. Now, you might notice that the Dover output is a lot smaller than the output.
See the difference between the size of the pit of the type and and many.
You might be wondering why that is OK. And the same thing happens with the variance that you use over at all our department.
We went on our our low resolution devices, the XP and the Varian.
We've been always magnifying the output by 30 percent.
So when you say one inch, it actually comes out one point three inches. And your points on that, the ten point type is really thirteen point type.
It's always it's actually larger on those machines because they were on they were just really hard to read at at the small side.
So so everything was wasn't what was coming on this artificial size.
And that's why and one of the first examples I talked about, true inches.
I said 11 true inches in that hand out because of true inches is is not subject to the enlargement.
If I said eleven inches, I would have gotten 14 or so inches. Okay.
So I said 11 through inches in the same. And that was using the SGP.
Now on the Dover everything point is a point. And so this is really ten point type that you're seeing on this Dover.
I'll put here this. Well, this was this is thirteen point five.
So coming out of the SGP now, that's so.
So if you look at the hand out, you've got the second day, you'll see the the the Dover output.
The calculus example was what was done was definitely a smaller type than on the hand out.
You've got the first day which was which was STPI. So there's this magnification that takes place on those low resolution devices.
The plan is that the cannon is high enough resolution that it will come out at one, two, one.
And so when you see one inch, it'll be on it. On the other hand, there is use for magnification even on the Dover.
And so it's possible to to it's possible now.
We've built we've built in a way to get magnification when you're printing things on the Dover.
This will soon be implemented also on other on other devices.
But right now, it's not working on the extra P or the very. But.
But this. But if you are using the Dover, you can use a feature of magnification whenever the fonts are available at magnified sizes.
Let me explain, first of all, what what it looks like by doing something I did this morning.
I haven't looked at these yet myself. I just can't pick them up on my way to class.
But I took this calculus example that we typed in the other day.
And on and I.
Oh, yeah. And I said magnified.
Well, let's see, I got to get these in the right order. I think this will be OK.
Yeah, I suppose. I think I have it right. I said magnify by by by 30 percent.
So this is exactly the same as your hand out. What you gonna hand out to but bigger cedo.
I don't have a copy of him. Not with me to somebody have one. Let's just put them side by side.
OK. So this was the, this was the original Dover I put in.
This is the 30 percent larger Dover.
Now I remember some mathematicians saying to me at first when they saw Tech that they always were so jealous of French
mathematicians who could have their journals come out with with larger type and they could speak in big letters.
When they do their mathematics. So here's your chance also, if you like that, you can also get it on the door.
Not only is it 30 percent larger than this one, but it's beautiful, beautiful compared to the SUV.
So. So. And it's exactly I didn't have to do anything with the file except one thing.
And that is after I had said infant basic. Then on the next line I said magnify.
Thirteen hundred.
Now I have to caution the people at Xerox if they're using teh basic which is which gives them times Roman text instead of other text,
you can't use this feature. It's only Ronni's working for the basic itself.
But I say magnify. Thirteen hundred and then everything.
This was, this is thirteen hundred means one point three times.
This is had to be an integer. We multiply by thousands.
Thirteen hundred means means one point three times the true size. The other sizes you can use.
So you can say 1000 which does nothing. Eleven hundred which is ten percent.
Twelve hundred thirteen hundred. Fifteen hundred. Two thousand and three thousand.
These are the main occasions that the fonts now exist for these seven different magnifications are allowed for all the fonts in basic.
And if you use another font besides one in basic, then then you might not find it available at high magnification yet.
But you should ask your local font wizard to see if, you know, if it's really important to you to get get a font at that size.
But that. But now that. So this is 30 percent larger, I believe.
And exactly the same source. Everything else was the same, except that the basic says that the that the margins are true.
Inches not in, not inches. So that the margins don't get enlarged.
So they. So I mean, the the language doesn't get in large. So you see that some things are paragraphs are gonna be broken differently.
This one what this paragraph is now three lines instead of two lines and so on. And and of course it's now the paper is two is two lines long.
All right. So I guess the question is, can you change the magnification within the text on it?
It can get very confused. Do it right at the very beginning.
It'll even get confused if you try to magnify it at the, you know, later on or something like that, because it uses this magnification several parts.
If you want to know exactly what the strictures are magnification are, you can read about it in the file on sales.
Colorada, Erato, dot, dot text.
This this file I should tell you about anyway. This file is we had one hundred copies lost in the mail between were between Rhode Island and here.
We were going to give out copies of this file but they didn't ever come.
Text comma VK. When is the file area. This file contains everything that's not in your manual.
Everything that's happened that's changed a little bit in tech and all corrections
to the manual typos and anything like that are in this are in this file.
So you could you can say Dover Arada dot text.
Take the UK and get a copy of that file if you want. If you and in fact, it's probably better to just print pages.
Gosh, what is it. Six to say six pages, six to nine.
Because the first five pages, you don't really need it. They're right up to the very early manuals of text that are that are better four years old.
But anyway, this this file contains contains information and has a lot has a rate of about magnifications in it, I believe.
Now, I played around with saying that by another question. Yes. No.
No. You have to use FCP. OK, I believe this was magnify at 15 hundred.
Let's see. Can we see it's getting still larger. Now, this is the kind of fifteen hundred.
This is about what I could use for if I would make an overhead projector slides and we'll see if we go back to the original.
Carolyn, don't let me walk off with your hand. But this was the original.
You know, I think this is really ten points size type. This is thirteen point ten and this is fifteen point.
Remember, when you're enlarging 30 percent. That's only in one dimension.
And actually, it's actually the area is going up by by one point thirty five, one point three.
So it's going up 70 percent an area. But 30 percent in in length.
So you're going to so. It's not just 10 percent can actually make a lot of difference in the case.
Yes. Wonder if you still want me to buy the whole file.
Just one. Fine. Yeah. It's possible just to magnify one fund.
Again, this is not implemented at scoring yet. But you see like this find a equals C.M.A 10 at 20 points.
Then you get. Then A will be a magnified ten point fund.
Will you actually be 20 points. And this is available at those magnifications that are there.
So I could take a ten point on it at 11, 12, 13, 15,
so I could also ask prosumer seven at twenty one points because that would be magnified three times.
But I can't ask for CMI seven at 20 points because that's magnified twenty seven times.
It's not one of the magnifications we have. I have a C.M.A seven at 14 points, C.M.A seven.
Whatever that is. So it's ten and a half points.
Okay. C.M.A. I can't ask s.m are eight at sixteen points would be would be double of C.M.A.
But but that's. But unfortunately that's not one of those in basic. So.
So we haven't prepared tmr eight. Magnification yet but also the ones that you that you really know are the fans that are in basic.
And those are listed in Appendix B, CMI, Tennessee, CMI seven, for example, are plants and basic.
They're all available in seven sizes. All the other fonts are available, at least at a level Adelaide at 10 percent magnification.
So so CMI eight, you can you could ask for eight point eight points.
Yeah. Question. It's like, Skip, can I want to skip the baseline?
Skip gets magnified with everything else.
So this is a photographically the same. This this is this magnification as if everything was blown up by the same scale factor.
So when you see one inch, it's going to come out one point three inches. Two.
And that's you ask for one two inch except the measure except the line measure, which was seven to two inches.
Yeah. How do you get back out of that. If you've asked for a piece of tape to be oh, no.
Well, I can select find a bike by calling a select this.
Let's find a and I'll find a it's just I mean, I can use s.m Martin at different magnifications in the same document if I select.
But if I give each one I want to be called funny. Want to be for golf on B.
Oh I see you did. So you know what you're saying here. Defining funny when you do that.
Yeah. This is another way to define. Yeah.
If the the the old way was just to say find a equal CMI 10 and magnify would then apply to the final version.
But if I say C on my 10 or 20 points and then I tried to magnify also, then, then this would have to be magnified further.
And as I said, at twenty through points, if I said 20 through points, then it would be then it would be the same if I say that twenty two point four.
That was also magnifying this document and I said magnify fifteen hundred.
And then I brought it and find a twenty points. It would actually be thirty points because of the notification that you're saying.
Yes, but I know it, it took me a while to get to get the ramifications of this all straight.
That's why I wrote it. That text is your answer has a lucid explanation in case of that.
Okay. Now I've got to show you the rest of these pictures. Yeah. Get that.
Oh, the graphs. Yeah.
You only want one of those things. Okay. Then you should you should do something like this.
Oh you you you should really sit in another font and ask for that font to be magnified because a
magnification should only be you should be uniform through throughout because it's not magnification.
It has to be computed for example when, when it's when the file is being sent out to the Dover.
Everything has to go all in the measurements have to be magnified by that amount in order to instruct it over what to do.
Now, let me show you what happened. I think I made this magnification two thousand and I was getting a small sample of math typing.
It's getting larger now. But, boy, now, I mean, you can't see how how beautiful it is unless they hold it up.
And I say, let's say hold it up. So this is the whole page, you know, I mean, this is a this you can really read.
This is four times in area, twice in width.
Okay. Now, still, the non-voice the paragraphs are getting a lot longer.
And if you look at the last page, you can probably see much more of the way I constructed this this arrow by cheating.
It's not a very good. Now you can see that I should have made them go a little closer together and things like that.
But this. But but, boy, a mathematician would be thrilled to see his mathematics coming out.
So it's like this printer could never do that for him. Really. So, OK.
Now. And so I went all the way and I said, magnified three times.
OK. So here I was, a sample.
Okay. Question on this page, I noticed the line spacing between two of the lines was funny right here.
Yeah. Yeah. This is because of this arrow, this cupie. There was no room for the arrow over the cupie.
And so so tech has to leave extra line. If you if you ever put a math formula in the middle of text that takes extra space, then.
Then it has to leave extra space for it in order for not to not to get written on top of the other one.
On the other hand, you might well want to ask the author not to do that because, you know, I was saying, you know, it's going to look bad.
And you think some other way to say that, you know, or can you display the formula instead?
But but that's what that's why that's fine. My spacing came came on.
In fact, it was true in the original book, as I as I mentioned the other day.
If you look at page 400, Verrett, if you see these lines here.
So the author must have known that those happen. That's gonna happen. Okay.
Now, now. So my three times magnified version here.
Notice my displayed form is still still coming out. Okay. However, I'm getting over four boxes.
How the center. This was done with a center line and center line. Doesn't really care if it goes into the left margin a little bit.
In fact, even to the twice sizes it went over and it didn't complain to me.
Didn't get any ah. Any, any messages. But on this one, when I said magnify three thousand I was getting over four box and the first.
One, it said a little bit too wide. Of course, it's magnified.
But this is a line that starts THC. And by the way, this one in brackets out here is means page one has just been completed.
And so I know that this awful box appears on page one or at least near the top of page two,
because it might have a process or something, starting with the word.
I know Anna. And an indentation. So was this very first line here. This is a little bit too wide.
OK. And. OK. Now then I had a few more and you'll see that something stick out as we go in here.
It coincides it didn't know how to hyphenate coincides. Apparently, some of the some of the sticking out was in in a displayed formula.
This one didn't fit that one. So serious. Notice I getting various things hyphenated here for it.
We've got to give a hand to the TV operator. This I'm closing him fits, but.
OK. Here's a word. Length is very hard to hyphenate. And typically.
Ha ha. OK. Now the reason is that now the reason I'm getting over four boxes of magnification,
three that I wasn't getting at magnification to or any of the lesser ones is that
all of a sudden I'm asking these paragraphs to be said to a much narrower measure.
Much. And and it's it's gonna be especially in mathematical text.
It'll be it'll be harder to find line breaks.
Tech has gone through this whole paragraph and said there's no way to set this paragraph so that you can achieve my tolerances,
which were very tight in their basic sets and without avoiding an overflow box on the first mining on this line here.
And No. So even moving as over here, that would mean putting quite a whitespace in the only place where you have room for space there and there.
This was defined to be acquired. I could acquire there. So that wasn't going to grow any.
And so I only have two places just to stretch that space.
And if I had to put the word as in there, all that room for the there had to be taken up there.
So it makes no space of just a little too wide for the tolerance. And and there is something and there is a way to change the tolerance.
And when you're setting to something to a narrow measure, then then it's inevitable out every hundred lines.
You're gonna you're you're gonna have some bad cases that can't be handled without increasing your tolerance.
Now, June this year coincides and couldn't hyphenate.
Is there a way to embed your own additional hibernation? So you just have to sprinkle discretionary hay, literally.
Right now, the way to to increase the number of words it can hyphenate is to use the exception
dictionaries built into our preprocessing routine that gets loaded with take at the beginning.
So we don't have a we don't have a commander's add it to the exception dictionary for hyphenation.
So so I, I think for use a text editor, if you give it's a if it's a word that you'll see a lot that you're using a lot in your in your text.
The fact that text is able to on on, on technical papers that it's able to to solve this problem with very tight restrictions because of its
because it takes a paragraph at a time means that you don't need to hyphenate very many words except that.
And so the number of times you're putting in discretionary hyphens turns out to be a
small amount of work compared to what you're already doing for proofreading anyway.
So. So we felt that getting the hyphenation down into the noise level,
that person isn't really spending very much of his own time putting in these extra hyphens compared to what's proofreading anyway.
Was it was fine for technical work.
On the other hand, if we were doing newspapers, we would we would either have to increase the tolerance which which which they always do anyway.
And then we would also want a more powerful hyphenation mechanism into it than it has now.
But the fact that the optimizers paragraph as a whole means that can usually find a way to do it without any hyphens.
It will only hyphens. And still having all of all of the space is quite nice.
Okay. Now, so what I would go through now and you know, this, this first line here, there is the question is what to do.
And in this case, I'm saying measures now or so I will increase my tolerance and the anthem Tazmania talks or talks about that called JPI.
I think we won't have time to discuss Capehart completely today, but I'll talk more about tomorrow.
And if I said and and if I said Jay PA equals equals twenty.
That would probably give me plenty of tolerance for this example. But I didn't.
Check it this morning. I should I should do so and tell it tomorrow.
I'll tell you how high I had to set Jay part before we were able to find good solutions to that particular tolerance.
Now, the the higher Jay Parr is, the more taller the more spaces are allowed to stretch.
This depends on the designer or the font. Has Toltec how much does spacing is desirable?
And. And for example, the normal thing for basic is to allow spaces that are between between four units,
minimum six units normal and open, about nine point one units maximum.
Now most printers actually say that they try to live between four and nine years maximum.
But the counts of the best printers say that actually about two lines out of every thousand,
they go up to 12 units even in the best printing and fifth and 18 units is one M.
Now, with the funds that we have, this would be J power.
If you had nine. Exactly. That would be J pa one nine point one is J.
Power to 12 corresponds to J power of eight.
Fifteen corresponds to a J. PA of twenty seven and 18 units corresponds to J.
PA sixty four. What happens is if every time you go up three units you, you add.
This is N cubed here. This is the words six plus three times the cube root of J PA.
For those mathematicians in the eyes is the formula that was actually used here.
It's a strange formula, but the main thing is twenty five means that you're going to lose face up to about 15 units, which is.
Which is which is fairly wide. Not not unusual in newspaper.
Sixty four means you're going to allow space up to a whole quite wide without without complaint.
And if there is a way to set the paragraph making those bases less than this tolerance, then it will do so.
Otherwise, we'll give you an overflow box and then you then.
Then it's your job to do some manual correction, to say how you'd like to handle the situation.
And of course, that's the net. That's what you want. Because the.
Because it's it's intolerably there's no tolerable way to do it.
So you have to do something now. Now, I said the talent's quite low in basic because I,
I was assuming that people were going to be making technical reports with fairly wide margins
that wouldn't be very bad and that they wanted really high quality looking upward documents.
And I kept that strict tolerance also throughout my book, whenever I couldn't solve a problem with that tolerance.
And this would occur maybe every 10, 15 pages. Well, I would think.
I really don't want to say that sentence quite that way.
You know, and I would and I would rewrite it in the vantages then that I can I can know that the book is going to be free of these.
Bernard Shaw said that he used to do this to his players when he would he would get back from the printer.
Some things they were they had terribly wide spaces. And so he would rewrite the thing so that it would look better and then they would they
wouldn't understand and they would reset some other lines and it would get worse. At least this little piece that we know now that that will take off.
So. So then the question is, if you're going to make some change for manual corrections to know what, what, what, what's available?
Well, the fact that we have the overflow box gives you some insight as to what the problem is,
is namely, I can I can look at this and I see I can't hyphenate the word length.
There isn't a room to fit. But but I could look at the word coincide. Where was the previous page?
And I could see that that coincides here. I can see that there would be plenty room to hyphenate.
The word coincides.
And so I can stick in my you see, text hyphenation rule looks mostly at adjacent letters and notes, whereas like similar that you would I hyphenates.
Yeah. I got to, I, I would think I could hyphenate that.
So that might have been, it couldn't stretch if there was to a stretch anywhere.
Oh OK. It's like. Yes. Now this is Frank Lange speaking.
He's the one, he's the author of The Hyphenation. And his thesis is also going to be.
And so in fact. That's right. This is the first line of a paragraph.
And I put a quiet space here. So this isn't isn't allowed to stretch the way the way I type that.
So it allows only stretching in between those words and and a three three spaces
wouldn't be enough to that would exceed that nine unit times nine is very stringent.
You won't find any printers who could guarantee you nine year spacing. I don't think they're right.
Well, is it reasonable to take a little space?